there's a difference between having a
thought about something and feeling a
certain way and actually biologically
physically being that thing yeah and so
so that's where you get into kind of a
gray area right it's like what actually
is something that I physically can be
what versus what can I feel like I am
well and what we're trying to say here
is that there are two physical genders
there are two things that you can be
when you're born you're either XX or XY
chromosome right genetically we only
exist in two forms but I feel like
um ostracizing the argument to
you know of course of course there are
men and women but we've created more
schools of thought more ways for people
to express themselves physically
okay so so if we're creating them that
means that they're not natural correct
not natural if they're man-made that
means they're not natural right that
whole non-natural thing brings up to
don't look to me this is between you two
right now no but it's it's usually you I
don't like this gimmick and I will not
be watching this video